en este vídeo comenzaremos a hacer la
deducción formal de la respuesta natural
de un circuito el s la respuesta de un
circuito inductor capacitor y esta es
una deducción difícil pero al final
tendremos una buena recompensa por
hacerlo ya que veremos que es aquí donde
se forman las ondas senoidal es y este
es un resultado genial porque las ondas
senoidal es se encuentran en todas
partes tanto en la electrónica como en
el mundo natural vamos a comenzar
poniendo una carga en este capacitor y
la corriente del circuito y va a
comenzar en cero así que y cero es igual
a cero
esta es la corriente a través de este
circuito lo que significa que esta
corriente también existe de este lado
pongamos un interruptor en este circuito
y vamos a cerrar el interruptor cuando
te sea igual a cero así que una de las
variables que vamos a usar es kim y la
otra variable va a ser be be es este
voltaje de aquí después de que se cierre
el interruptor
así que queremos encontrar ahí llave y
para esto nos vamos a enfocar en
encontrar ahí ya que si encontramos ahí
será muy sencillo encontrar ave así que
esta va a ser nuestra variable
independiente la corriente comencemos el
análisis y cuando el tiempo te sea igual
a 0 la carga que se encuentra aquí va a
comenzar a fluir en el circuito y tanto
el voltaje como la corriente van a
comenzar a cambiar así que comencemos
escribiendo algunas cosas que sabemos
que son verdaderas acerca de nuestros
componentes comencemos con el capacitor
comenzamos escribiendo la expresión para
nuestro capacitor y aquí va a haber un
cambio de signo así que hay que tener
cuidado si yo tengo ve en un capacitor y
en un capacitor puedo decir que el
capacitor va a ser igual hace por debe
ser porque es el capacitor dt y si vemos
aquí bc es la misma que la ve que
tenemos aquí el signo positivo arriba
aquí y acá también el signo negativo
por lo que a veces son iguales pero con
y debemos tener cuidado y se encuentra
en la dirección opuesta a la corriente
que elegí como variable independiente
así que esto está invertido así que
nuestra y tendrá un signo negativo está
ahí es igual a menos se debe
dt y esta es la ecuación y ve de este
circuito en particular que tiene este
signo negativo extra ahora voy a
escribir la forma integral de la
ecuación y ved el capacitor b es igual a
1 en 13 que multiplica a la integral de
i
dt y no olvidemos nuestro signo negativo
ahora encontremos el voltaje a través de
nuestro inductor el voltaje del inductor
es igual a la misma variable b igual a l
por el dt y aquí no tenemos un signo
negativo extra esto tiene el signo de
acuerdo a la convención de los
componentes pasivos así que tenemos una
expresión para b en él
pastor y una expresión para ver en el
inductor y sabemos que ambos son el
mismo voltaje así que pongamos estas
cosas juntas podemos decir que el del dt
es igual a menos 1 en 13 por la integral
de i
dt lo único que hicimos fue igualar
estas ecuaciones que son del mismo
voltaje y ahora vamos a manipular las un
poco tenemos que el del dt más 1 en 13
por la integral de i
dt es igual a 0 simplemente pusimos
todos los términos del lado izquierdo y
dejamos 0 en el lado derecho y ya que no
estoy acostumbrada a tener integrales
aquí en estas ecuaciones realmente yo
prefiero tener derivadas ya que tengo
cierta experiencia con ecuaciones
diferenciales así que vamos a tomar la
derivada de toda esta ecuación vamos a
encontrar la derivada con respecto a t
de todo esto de aquí
y esto nos da la segunda derivada de
este primer término tenemos l por la
segunda derivada de y con respecto al
tiempo más 1 en 13 y la derivada de la
integral de y dt resulta que es
simplemente iu y la derivada de 0 en
este lado es igual a 0
y esta es la ecuación diferencial del
circuito lc y tiene un nombre es una
ecuación diferencial ordinaria homogénea
de segundo orden
es una ecuación diferencial porque tiene
derivadas es homogénea porque sólo tiene
derivadas de i con respecto a t y nada
más el indicador es que tenemos este
lado igual a cero no tenemos ningún
término forzado de este lado así que
cuando podemos escribir la ecuación de
esta manera decimos que es homogénea y
es de segundo orden porque tiene esta
segunda derivada aquí así que tenemos
nuestra ed o homogénea de segundo orden
establecida y en el siguiente vídeo la
vamos a resolver la resolveremos paso a
paso